peintures datant de 1911 à celle du show
qui est né à blainville en 1987 à 24 ans
il abandonnera la peinture
traditionnelle deux ans plus tard en
1913 il deviendra ce réaliste mais avant
adhéra au mouvement dada où il prendra
le pseudonyme de rrose sélavy mais
revenons à la peinture cubiste que nous
voyons donc j'étais pas entrer dans le
cubisme
au début j'étais jeu l'arrivée d'un
jugement en 10 11 11 même pas super gt
pas je n'étais pas un fondateur dans le
tarn il est fondateur et j'ai pris ça un
peu comme une arme une expérience comme
j'avais fait d'ailleurs avec le four vij
mai et même un peu l'impressionnisme que
j'avais 15 ans quand séquence était
encore là une exploration n'a pas pour
moi en tout cas
et cette exploration n'a pas duré très
longtemps comme loyer car en 1912 au
début d'ailleurs de 1912 j'ai fait ces
dons c'est un an juillet 1912 je suis
allé à munich pour faire ce tableau pas
pour le faire mais je n'ai je les fais à
mener avec deux ou trois autres sur ces
deux mois et c'est là où s'est
déclenchée vraiment le déclic
la session civile dans mon esprit et mon
abandon
détrompe influencé par le public